bonjour and sorry for the delay but
we had the lux prize in the chamber and therefore
we lost a few minutes for me it is
only accompanying the new
president of the commission at the end
of a process which, as you have seen, is
very busy in the parliament is a
process that we have taken seriously
we conducted with great transparency
indeed I thank all the press the
journalists the communicators who
followed the formation of the new
commission I
am very happy that the president
has reiterated that we need
new policies and new reforms for
the European framework I
am very happy that she has done so
reference to the possibility of giving life
to a conference on
European democracy in which the parliament is also the
protagonist and this is very very important for us
as of today we start working we are
the parliament Mrs von der leyen it
will be the commission of course the
collaboration
the success of this  start of the
legislature will be able to determine  draw some
conclusions which are the ones that the
citizens asked us during the
electoral campaign so thank you all and I give
the floor to the lady please merge them
kind of conference group
pareva mans end of change and change and
unique solid change and nothing to say
i'm  on next week
and i think that is more david carretta
radio radical one question in italian
in honor of multilingualism two
questions actually the first one you had a
larger majority than jean claude
junker
but at the same time the political forces of
this majority on some dossiers
how immigration and climate
change have already begun to
experience each other we saw a
resolution on sea rescues in October that
did not pass we will probably see it
tomorrow on the climate emergency he believes he
has a solid enough majority to
carry out his program
and on the geopolitical commission for  a
normal citizen the geopolitical commission at the
geopolitical european union
should a  go and resolve
the crises also outside Syria but there is
no European army or knowing how to criticize
China when it puts a million people in a gulag
in internment camps
and the European Union is
unable to react with  come on
what is the geopolitical commission
soda di lingua migration and nash mail
way parole factor way and violence nel
marquinhos at the red house weekend of low
cost
wayne rooney bbb export technologies in
finance of opinion unique features
in opinion tournaments france to them
money money for nothing but the european
union and are we shall be
box office national home and i will be
your shape
mar.ming holden bene con lei da udb
storico guidelines intense years ago email
for you why did you choose the week est
link
screenshots main  music stage melts
in via filanda di sequins shoes shirt
with with the script a baguette sting
mazziniano die panne yen my courtesy
stop in moscow the president club there is
an app in commis  sion
an institution idea of ​​little fish
commission institution president
barbara by franz marc grossman bossi
in hong kong and the possibility
info develop and is perhaps the most possible i
had two macedonians of no and albania
triple a noto qt and with the stage of the
btp june  papin
servetto but the president will speak
if it will be called via speak to the world
while compass there was also the holy see
castion lin and so much in the tastes and minister
of defense from the tycoon sour that the most
concrete
the def asero thought of bishop budri is
that if  at the end of set
and also for the occasion hatched the
good real madrid while his method
climate madrid pur donia cool of scoop
on the post season climate port the
commission therefore proposes a the look
at the european union all on topic
i think malindi fans
[  Music]
spacey swiss finance and technology and
technologies e mail
maybe technologies inc in montana
muta fi kim clijsters implies climate estimate
[Music]
just a frank report d  the saint and type
of president can have meetings
intended for such identity and thunder
line to the teeth identity are gasmi teti
million people goddess luchi identity
iced a speech a little so-so cool
hunting party games hub a thin light of
tunes entities moment of identity
[  Music
] thank you for this question it
seems to me that if there was anyone in the
world who was indignant he protested
about what is happening in
northern syria yes it was europe in part in
particular the european parliament
we were very clear on the  affair
on the responsibilities of the
Turkish authorities we also recently repeated it
to the minister of Turkey not
only our indignation but our
willingness for the Turkish authorities to
review their position
it seems to me that in this we
express the solidarity that has been expressed to the
citizens of the  north of syria is very
very clear and very precise
this taken by males 90 identity
the eighth data on country fashion others me
it seems to me it seems to me that
we were clear on this too in our
resolution and our protest was
exactly against
Kurdish citizens he we we don't I want to be
very clear
sorry we can do many things
we can have diplomatic actions
we can when it is  it was possible to
participate in peace missions but
we are not directly responsible for
what happens around the world
we can express our strength
and our policy to ensure
that there is no violence this we
can do but we are not responsible
of the violence that others unleash
not only in the Middle East but in many
parts of the world there are currently 60
conflicts but Europe is not responsible
then we have the responsibility to take
charge of so many things
we want to equip ourselves with millions of instruments
we want to have more diplomacy  capable
because we want to resolve conflicts
with diplomacy not with weapons
qu  then everything that Europe can
do of course, however not everything is in
our hands
because if these make everything fall back
on Europe, I believe that it is not useful, in short,
the question of the Kurdish people in
many countries of the Middle East is a
question that we  we would like to help
solve and last question angela
mauro huffington post italia for
president provide it yen in july ind
hispania matthew top di batte form of
dublin regulation today you did mansion
in hit parade
this is still priority neuro gen the
president
yes three considerations first of all
thank you  the president because she used
very clear words,
for example in replying to her
journalist colleague on the question of the EU budget
I would not like people to forget that
dialogue with parliament is essential
for anyone because it is the parliament that
votes on the budget and we said so
very clearly in the
Finnish semester we will also tell the others and
we will tell the board that no  i want to
be part of the negotiation on the
budget otherwise i don't know what the
opinion of the parliament will be on the budget and
i am pleased that the commission from the
president von der leyen have said
from day one that the parliament must
be an actor in the negotiation of the
budget
i would like that  let this be clear
it is not optional to discuss with
parliament I believe that everyone should not hear it
because some budget hypotheses
in parliament will not pass
I want to be very explicit the second
question
we are I am very happy that as
I said before the president reiterated in her
speech  the importance of this
journey that we want to take together
to put European democracy back in order
we have seen that everyone is
starting to discuss this
there was a Franco-German no paper there is
an argument with the council that we are
beginning to  engage in this
discussion the parliament has already set
up a working group for a
method  logy to be naturally submitted
to the commission and the council will be a
path that will accompany us throughout
the legislature and ensure that
European democracy is stronger and
above all has the ability to
respond to problems
more effectively than the
democracy we defend today  if it responds
to the needs of citizens
and then we need
stronger and more adequate mechanisms for this purpose
third question
I wanted to give you third information is that on
Sunday we will meet in brussels at the
house of european history which is the museum
that the european parliament has  equipped
and who tells our story we
will meet with Mrs von der
leyen with the new Prime
Minister with President lagarde
because Sunday is December 1st and
the legislature will start and this
will naturally also be the way for us
to donate to President von der  leyen
and the treaties because since Sunday the
president von der leyen is the cus  tode
of the European treaties for which I
thank you